hello everyone and welcome to the final
day of the saint louis rapid and blitz
tournament uh and it's not only the
final day it's a game from the final
round
ahikaru nakamura vs jeffrey xiong and a
lot of you have requested
it's a very fun game and it features the
probably the most popular
opening in online chess which is of
course the bong
cloud and it's not very often that
someone would play this against 2700
plus grandmaster
but it is exactly what happened here and
okay um
some consider this the bomb clouds uh
magnus crossing said that he considers
f3 followed by king to f2 uh the actual
bomb cloud
sorry about that but it doesn't really
matter uh as if you play king to
you know e2 or f2 i i think all of that
is considered the bomb cloud
so hikaru goes e4 we have e5 and here
king to e2 debunk cloud is on the board
uh and
uh well it's uh it's a very strange
thing to play against
anyone especially against someone as
strong as jeffrey xiong young
because if you put this position on any
engine it will tell you
uh black is winning uh but that's
easier said than done i mean you have to
still play very good moves and you
have to play a good game now white's
main issue is
here is that he's blocking the queen
he's blocking the development of the
bishop
uh he's gonna have to waste at least
three to four more moves at the castle
artificially at some point
and now the question is can black take
advantage of advantage of this um
immediately or will he have to uh try
and slow play it
now uh the worst thing you could do is
just to go all out and try to checkmate
the white king because that will
pretty much never work and you're just
gonna lose the game so xiong just
continues uh developing naturally he
attacks the pawn here
uh and uh he's just gonna try and go for
a normal game
uh and uh he's just gonna he he will
just hope that hikaru's king on e2 will
be
a big enough problem in itself to uh you
know
just uh ruin his game so here at d3
there is a game actually in database
where knight to c3 was played
uh but here he cargoes d3 and it is as
of move three that we have a completely
new game
we have d5 by xiong uh of course makes
sense as you add another attacker to the
pawn here and you want to open up the
center as hikaru's king still is on
e2 knight d2 adding another defender and
now
knight to c6 knights to c6 with c3 by
hikaru controlling that knight
and b6 now at some point the bishop
might come to this diagonal
the king still is on e2 we have queen to
c2
and now bishop to b7 uh knight g2 f3
car continues developing and queen to d7
preparing to castle queen side
with b4 by hikaru uh he's like uh
saying uh i i don't i really don't mind
that my king is on e2 i'm just gonna
start attacking on the queen side
so here sheon castles and now a3 so it's
a
it's a really funky set up a3b for c3
there's some action going on here in the
center
and there's a king on e2 so at some
point this king will have to go
somewhere so we'll see what happens king
b1
uh sorry king b8 xing still not doing
anything crazy he's still just uh
normally developing as if uh nakamura's
king was for example on g1 rook on f1
and
the bishop on e2 it would be it would be
an interesting game uh bishop to b2 by
hikaru and
g6 now and finally king to e1 now hikar
will
try to develop the bishop of the rook
and get the king to safety with bishop
to h6
and now rook to d1 and of course rook h
to e8 and
if you look at the position now uh
jeffrey's position is just wonderful he
has a very nicely developed knights the
bishops are slicing
uh across the board the rooks are
beautifully placed here on the d
and on the e file and if the position
now opens up
it's pretty much it's pretty much a win
for black so here bishop to e2
and now knight to h1 uh h5 preparing to
shift the knight over to f4 with b5 by
by hikaru and knight to a5 and now c4
and with this little maneuver
hikaru is uh has successfully chased
this knight to the edge of the board but
it's of little use if you if you get
checkmated
so here knight to f4 putting pressure on
the g2 pawn so bishop back to f1 by
hikaru
still the king stuck on e1 and now d
captures on c4
a bit faster with d captures on e4 as
there's a much more pressure here on the
e4 pawn and also you will have support
for f5
however xion goes for d captures on c4
which is still a perfectly fine move
uh we have d captures and only now f5 so
the king is in the center
you have to bust open the center c5 by
hikaru he continues attacking with his
king on e1 threatening c6 to win some
material
but xiong doesn't care he just plays f
captures on e4
with c6 by hikaru now with a double
attack on the bishop and on the queen
and just knight captures on c6 with this
maneuver he grabs two pawns and
gets his knight away from the edge of
the board captures captures
and now knight captures an e5 with an
attack on jeffrey's queen and the bishop
here on c6
so here if you do pretty much anything
other than the move
that was played in the game it's really
not going to be all that great you
either play rook captures on e5 and
allow bishop captures or
what was played in the game knight to d3
with
check and now it doesn't really matter
what white plays here because
even if you if you capture the knight uh
or you you try something
uh well you're gonna have problems
because the rook and the king are on the
same file
so here he carl played bishop captures
on d3 but now just
e captures on the e3 attacking the queen
and also
you will not be capturing anything today
because well now the knight is pinned so
queen to c for by hikaru
uh still with pressure on the bishop
here although uh
as long as there's this pin you will not
be able to do anything about it
uh now bishop captures on g2
attacking hikaru's rook rook to g1 and
now bishop back to b7
and here hikaru tried uh queen to h4 now
putting pressure on the bishop here
and it's a very interesting position
xing still with with a beautiful bishop
pair as you can see the rooks are really
really awesome here uh it's uh it's a
terrible position for hikaru
and uh there are so many winning moves
here for for hyung like
just moving the bishop is winning queen
to b5 is winning going after the bishop
uh however the move xiung plays is not
so much winning he played queen to f5
now with a double attack on the knight
here but hikaru says
uh okay if i'm counting this right i'm
just gonna be
up a lot a lot of material if i just
capture the bishop and this is exactly
what hikaru does
uh he goes queen captures on h6 we have
rook captures on e5
bishop captures and now queen captures
with the czech and now
hikaru's king is in a terrible position
but if it's not
checkmated then hikaru is just up a
whole rook
so here queen backed the e3 by hikaru
and now queen captures on h2
attacking the rook king f1 and now queen
to h5 putting pressure on the other rook
as well with
f3 and now bishop to c6 with ideas that
maybe
if at some point this pawn is captured
bishop to b5 could be really problematic
for white
so queen g5 now that he carries up a
rook he just wants to trade everything
uh so queen h3 check of course xion
cannot allow a queen trade here king f2
and now queen to h2 with
check and of course hikaru no longer
satisfied with uh
with adjusted rock rook the g2 attacks
cheong's queen
queen back to d6 and now rook to e1
uh we have rook to f8 putting pressure
on the f3 pawn even though the knight is
still defending it
rook king back to g1 we rook to f5
attacking hikaru's queen and the queen
to e7 hikaru just offers a trade with
queen to f4
but now uh hikaru does the only thing
reasonable he goes after the d3 pawn
which means
queen to d8 with check this is what
hikaru does queen d8
check king b7 and queen captures on d3
and without the past d3 pawn
uh it's just a much worse position for
black
like we could say it's a worse position
for white but white is upper rook so
that's why his position is not all that
terrible
uh we have rook to d5 going after the
queen if the queen moves you might
be able to capture the knight but just
queen e3 so everything is nicely
defended
uh queen to h4 and now queen to f2
blocking the queen
queen back to a4 and now rook to e3 he
carl just
keeps everything nicely defended queen
to d1
with check but now just king air queen
to a1 of course hikaru
only needs to trade and he will be
winning queen to a4
and rook the c3 now so what do you do
here
rook to h5 by xiong trying to to stir
some trouble here
but rook to g4 hikaru is just lifting
one
rook by a rook by rook you know the
lifts are happening so queen to a5
and now queen to c1 with a double attack
on the bishop here we have queen the e5
uh hoping that uh if rook captures on c6
then xiong has queen to e3 check king g2
and queen to e2 check
where hikaru would be forced to accept a
draw by repetition because if you go
king g3
uh queen to h2 will be checkmate the
king doesn't have anywhere to go
so after his queen to e5 move hikaru not
want to be
tricked easily goes knight to f1 just
covers all the important squares here
uh and here queen to e6 just defending
that bishop
but now it's a completely lost position
so feel free to pause the video here and
win the game for hikaru while i give you
a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
adding more attackers to the c6 bishop
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show
it's the wills the fairly simple rook
uh rook g to c4 and now there's a triple
attack on the bishop and you cannot add
any more defenders than there already
are like okay you could play rook to c5
but
i mean trading down does not help you
when you're down the rook
so there's really not much here uh xiong
played bishop to b5 but now hikaru just
breaks through rook captures on c7 with
check king a6 and now even a4
offering a pawn to open up the the a
file as well
so bishop back to e2 but now rook to e3
with a double attack so the next move is
forced uh rook to g5 check
this is not possible it wasn't this
check was not possible before because
the queen was covering this square
but king f2 and now there is no
uh there's really not much you can do
the bishop has no squares all of these
squares are taken so you cannot really
move the bishop
uh sheen played queen to h3 uh hoping
for some
some maybe blunder from hikaru but
hikaru just played king captures on e2
and it was in this position on mu52 that
jeffrey shiong resigned the game
and what a victory for hikaru nakamura
in the final round of the saint louis
blitz uh tournament
uh winning uh with and none other than
the the bong cloud
now here you resign because well you're
down a rook and a piece and of course
you don't have anything uh with with
best play
uh black is getting uh black is getting
checkmated
in let's say some 12 moves uh and uh the
the question is why did hikaru go for
the bomb cloud here did he lose some
sort of a bet with someone maybe with
his viewers or maybe
he just wanted to show jeffrey who
really whose boss uh
none of that actually uh he already had
his place secured in the tournament and
uh it
it was going to be the exact same place
regardless of how
he played this game he could lose he
could win he could draw uh it doesn't
matter so he just decided to have fun
went for the bomb cloud and in the end
uh did not go for the for the most
precise continuation at that
moment that we've shown and of course
hikaru won the game
so really crazy stuff uh we're not gonna
uh mention the standings just yet as we
are going to show at least one more game
uh but yeah uh that's uh the game i do
hope you enjoyed it
uh you know if you if you enjoyed the
bong club do play it as you can see it's
not that easy for black to break through
even if he's a 27
uh uh 100 plus grand master so you know
do try do try it online and have have
some fun with it
i would like to thank bart carpenter tom
hathartwaite uh dirk van morick
sean chadwick and jason clark for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the saint
louis rapidom blitz tournament with at
least one more game checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your sunday